la seule crainte qui avait ma mère
c'était pour les enfants il craignaient
que les enfants ne souffrent
d'être métisse et elle avait peur que
que les gens ne soient pas gentils avec
eux
je crois que c'est
[Musique]
allô c'est toi Jean salut vieux est-ce
que tu l'as fait le numéro 3 l'exercice
d'allemand là
comment tu dis j'apporte non oui c'est
ça j'apporte
tu te rappelles plus ou alors j'arrive
tout de suite
est-ce que je peux aller chez Jean
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dans une maison
en fait ton Ton père il a déjà été
[Applaudissements]
retourné une fois quand il était
chouette il devait étudiant comme ça et
puis une autre fois il est retourné il y
a un an puis ta mère non on voyait
jamais été et est-ce que tu aimerais
habiter là-bas ou alors qu'est-ce que tu
préfères la France ou alors là-bas je ne
sais pas je connais pas
je connais pas là-bas
[Applaudissements]
c'est une très bonne élève vous savez en
définitive je voudrais savoir si elle a
fait des progrès au point de vue
discipline
vous savez elle est un petit peu bavarde
depuis deux ou trois mois et certains
qu'elle est un peu bavard les enfants je
trouve que son attitude presque plus
normal qu'il y a quelques temps
elle était vraiment
trop renfermée pour plier sur elle-même
trop gras voyez pour une enfant de son
âge je trouve c'est une enfant qui se
lit difficilement et qui garde ses
distances pendant un certain temps avant
d'être d'adopter une attitude ou une
autre
je crois que c'est dans son caractère
santé un petit peu distante toujours sur
la réserve et même presque tu sais dans
la santé
ça a été très net là depuis trois mois
je la trouve enfin je dirais presque
normal
[Musique]
la journée
tu as pensé à ce départ
je ne pense qu'à ça
en fait
[Musique]
tout ce qui est traditionnel ça existe
encore non oui tradition il faut se
méfier aussi parce que l'Afrique évolue
énormément alors quand on s'en va là-bas
avec des idées que tu as toi c'est à
dire j'ai l'impression que tu vois
l'Afrique un peu dans les bouquins
[Musique]
où tu ne pourras pas entrer ça je te
promets tout de suite bon il y a des
milieux vraiment extra non je sais même
pas ça
quand nous allons chez des amis
africains ou quand des amis africains
viennent chez nous c'est habituellement
mon mari qui fait le marché et la
cuisine
parce que nous faisons de la cuisine
africaine et évidemment il sentir
beaucoup mieux que moi
j'ai plus je suis contente de d'éplucher
les légumes ou de nettoyer les poissons
et lui il fait la cuisine
avec un grand tablier devant lui c'est
très drôle je crois qu'il prend beaucoup
de plaisir d'abord ça lui rappelle sans
doute le pays
et puis je crois qu'il aime ça au fond
ces réunions
sont évidemment très agréables parce que
nous sommes entre amis
mais aussi ça me permet et je suppose
que c'est pour les autres pareil ça nous
permet de
de connaître un petit peu
de façon de vivre
[Musique]
ne sont pas les miennes
et
de faire en sorte de lien avec ma
famille qui est en Afrique
[Musique]
vous allez y aller aussi je crois oui je
vais y aller pour huit jours seulement
en fait c'est déjà merveilleux et vous
avez des enfants qu'est-ce qui va les
garder les parents
[Musique]
deux garçons de filles c'est vos parents
qui me regardent
[Applaudissements]
quand nous vous sortons soit avec les
enfants soient seuls
très souvent les gens se retournent
sur notre passage
quelquefois c'est une simple curiosité
comme ça
j'ai pas l'impression que ça aille plus
loin que vos fausses sont des regards
plus ou moins hostiles et d'autres fois
des paroles plus ou moins désagréables
au début ça me vraiment
peiné ça m'a peut-être plus révolté que
peiner d'ailleurs
[Applaudissements]
mais maintenant mon dieu il fait même
plus tellement attention
la force n'est pas un pays raciste mais
le racisme il faut le reconnaître existe
en France dans le métro dans le train
dans la rue dans le bus j'aime pas la
maison
nous en parlerons comme ça
aussi froidement et aussi calmement que
possible
de façon à ne pas aggraver la chose mais
afin de montrer qu'elle que c'est là
donc ça existe
à l'école tu rappelles dans cette série
je crois à l'école gratuit
[Applaudissements]
je crois que lorsque les gens réagissent
devant vous comme ça a été le cas ce
soir dans le train
le muscle de ne rien dire parce que
sinon
il n'y aurait jamais d'amitié entre les
gens mais je crois quand même que j'ai
tort de dire de ne rien dire car à force
de ne rien dire on passe pour toujours
pour une victime il faut le temps d'un
temps réagir alors est-ce que
mal
oui
elle est plus haute que moi alors elle
se croit plus intelligent
Antoine et grâce ça va alors on se
dispute
[Applaudissements]
que par la force parce que je sais bien
que
si je vois qu'on croise trop longtemps
je
m'énerve et puis c'est pas trop mal
alors
j'essaie de rester plus calme
[Applaudissements]
mes parents sont en retraités ma mère
était directrice d'école maternelle
et quand nous nous sommes connus au mari
et moi
leur attitude a été vraiment formidable
et non pas un seul instant
ni de position
la seule crainte qui avait ma mère
c'était pour les enfants elle traînaient
que les enfants ne souffrent
d'être métisse et avait peur que que les
gens ne soient pas gentils avec eux que
les enfants petits puissent en souffrir
[Applaudissements]
de mon grand-père je veux dire
nous sommes plus près de 200
alors moi j'occupe
ridicule
quand il réuni tout ça ça doit être un
sport oui mais
envahissante
heureusement tout le monde n'est pas
audermé sinon ça ferait
de côté c'est une somme chrétienne de
côté kenom chrétien catholique en
général pas Bigot on voit la maison on y
va pas chacun
des animistes ma mère je crois que vous
l'avoir déjà dit
pour la première fois
je sais pas très bien en fait lequel des
deux donnent plus troublé oui je crois
en effet qu'il était aussi plus quoi
mais tu sais
au fond il m'a été sympathique du
premier coup mais
ça me paraît c'est quand même quelque
chose d'assez
au début j'étais un peu inquiète
moi je me demandais si c'était bien de
se faire se mariage après tout c'était
tellement quelque chose extraordinaire
je n'avais jamais vu
dans ce pays moi maintenant
est-ce que c'est quelque chose de normal
enfin j'ai écouté la raison je me suis
dit mais enfin qu'est-ce que tu
reproches à ce jeune homme là
il avait toutes les qualités que
j'aurais aimé dans un futur Jean
et puis quand je viens réfléchis je me
suis dit mais enfin qu'est-ce que je
crains
c'est ce que pensais les autres
et après tout qu'est-ce que ça peut me
faire je commence les autres
ce voyage en Afrique va être un voyage
très important qui m'arrive car ce sera
pour elle prise de contact
elle qu'on ne mes parents parlent les
photos nous envoie
par la lettre que lui envoie souvent son
beau-père donc mon père et ma sœur les
cousins maintenant il faut qu'elle voit
les gens
se forcer à eux dire tout va se décider
dans un instant que moi
je n'appréhende pas celui de ma famille
mais que elle sûrement Redoute
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
est très heureuse
de recevoir ce jour
on est parti depuis longtemps revenu
parmi nous ainsi que son épouse
oh non je ne vais pas vous infliger un
discours loin de là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et de retour en Europe quand vous aurez
l'occasion de recevoir des invités
[Applaudissements]
ça va
[Musique]
rien caché
il est parti
du Dahomey
vers septembre 1948
et
après trois ans de ses études
et nous a écrit je veux être fiancé
de la fille de cette fin de la famille
qui s'occupe de moi
elle est une étudiante elle aussi
si tu si vous voulez
autoriser moi aller avec elle nous
n'avons pas répondu
à sa lettre
un mois après
la mère de Maryvonne nous a écrit pour
dire que
vraiment que notre fils
s'attache à sa fille
qu'elle tienne tous deux à se marier moi
je suis content
45000 habitants maintenant
la ville s'étale on voit des immeubles
que moi je ne connaissais pas tu verras
cette ville vraiment insaisissable on ne
peut pas saisir que tout le monde c'est
une ville extrêmement complexe il y a de
tout le temps
et puis parmi les Noirs il y a
plusieurs ethnies qui se mélangent
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
Philippe une cocotte très je crois
environ 18 km de Cotonou il a l'habitude
d'y aller tous les dimanches avec sa
femme et ses enfants
et il a voulu nous y emmener pour passer
un dimanche
c'est vraiment très très agréable
[Applaudissements]
nous avons été invité à Porto-Novo chez
des amis
de couple mixtes comme nous
l'une des jeunes femmes est infirmière
au lycée son mari est professeur de
sciences naturelles et l'autre jeune
femme et professeur
d'histoire-géographie et son mari est
plombier
les gens qu'elle est en train
d'ici mais c'est incroyable tous les
gens qui sont venus
pour vous faire plaisir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vos mesures on vous apporte des costumes
qui vous vendent justement
on dit que les enfants sont une richesse
une richesse familiale
je suis très heureuse d'avoir fait ce
voyage là parce que je crois que c'est
vraiment une étape
nécessaire
très importante
c'est quand même assez difficile de
s'habituer
d'un seul coup
à une vie nouvelle
des habitudes nouvelles
des gens nouveaux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]